this is not going to be your typical how
to cure your food baby
bloat video hey everyone i'm abby sharp
welcome to abby's kitchen outside the
kitchen
[Music]
today is going to be a bit of a vlog
video and i'm going to take you along
with me
on a bit of a journey that i'm having i
thought it might be interesting because
i
bet there are some of you who are
secretly silently
struggling with something very similar
gas pain kind of a little bit of a less
sexy topic
when we compare it to something like
stomach bloating which as i always say
has kind of become
the socially acceptable code word for
how to lose weight but i gotta be honest
even though obviously i am dealing with
severe bloating as a result of this gas
pain
this is so not my priority like this has
nothing to do with the size or shape of
my belly
hard stop now before we get into things
of course my general disclaimer is
on the screen as well as in the
description below if you want to check
that out but this may be
a bit of a embarrassing and
uncomfortable conversation for most
people to have
but i gotta tell you as a dietitian
nothing
bow-related phases me dietitians talk
about poop
all day every day but a bit of a
backstory
so pregnancy and postpartum and all that
totally wreaked havoc on my digestion
now most moms or moms to be deal with a
lot of constipation that's like a
typical
pregnancy side effect and it sucks but i
didn't have that problem i had the
opposite problem
i was having a hard time keeping things
in
like to put it vaguely just trying to
keep things clean here folks
literally as soon as i gave birth that
all seemed to resolve itself
but instead what i got was this like
debilitating
gas pain and bloating pain now like i
always say it is 100
normal for your belly to expand and
contract
throughout different times of the day or
different times of the week or month
we need to normalize these bodily
processes we really do
like we we can't expect everyone to just
wake up in the morning with a flat
stomach and go to bed at night with a
flat stomach just
not realistic but i would like to of
course fix this problem not so much
because
you know any aesthetic reasons or
because it doesn't look so hot but
because
the pain from this gas can be so
debilitating
that it literally will keep me up at
night i also can't say for sure
why this is or what like the reason for
this is hormones do
crazy things and i can never predict
what's gonna happen
whether it's in breastfeeding or
pregnancy or trying to get pregnant etc
however the working theory is that it
has something to do with
my diastasis recti um and what that is
is basically the separation of the
abdominal
wall muscles in pregnancy and it
happened pretty severely to me because
i don't know if you saw my instagram
stories um during pregnancy but
baby oh was a legitimate acrobat like
we're going straight to the olympics
that's for sure because
it was intense so i really wasn't
surprised when i went to the pelvic
floor physio and
she assessed me and she was like yeah
you got like a pretty
deep deep deep three finger separation
which basically means if she put you put
like three fingers that's
hard to do three fingers together she
can like push that
down between my two abdominal muscles
and it'll just go like
rip all the way down to like whatever
organs are in there it's
it's really terrifying to watch it
happen for me you know diastasis recti
can mean
that you have pelvic floor issues like
peeing yourself all the time
and also of course digestive issues
because things are just kind of like
not well aligned in there anymore now if
you were to search
you know how to deal with bloating on
youtube or instagram or or on the
internet
you're gonna find a bunch of influencers
who are telling you to you know
eliminate this or restrict that go on an
elimination diet
whatever i have to be honest obviously i
know all about this i'm a registered
dietitian
but between covid and work being crazy
and trying to raise two babies
i barely have time to feed myself never
mind have to
think through a whole new elimination
diet and restricting things and finding
new foods and finding alternatives and
all that kind of stuff food is such a
joy for me in these really isolating
times in covet time so
ugh the thought of having to like
restrict some of my favorites really
bums me out and also i'm a little weary
of restricting foods that i really like
just because of my history with
orthorexia and actually my orthorexia
started
as a result of an elimination diet and i
really am all for like adding things to
my diet or or adding things to my
lifestyle or finding little tweaks that
i feel like
i can digest no pun intended
but i don't want to do anything extreme
i'm just not
ready for that to get a little bit more
insight i brought in
my colleague and friend andrea hardy who
specializes in gi health as a registered
dietitian
so thank you so much for joining me
andrea thank you for having me today
okay so give it to me quick give it to
me straight because
i got a lot on my plate andrea so what
are the three things that i really need
to focus on this week
yes so instead of taking out food or
focusing on elimination diets
uh three simple things you can do the
first
biggest one is making sure you chew your
food well
and so of course that requires us to
take a little bit of time when we're
eating which
as a mom of two is probably very tricky
uh so slowing down making sure you start
the digestive process in your mouth and
chewing well can really prepare your
body to
digest and get things moving the second
one
i know you enjoy drinking bubbly water
we've talked about it before
consuming a lot of air or bubbles when
we
drink can definitely contribute to
bloating and gas
in fact one study showed that when we
consume
carbonated beverages the air can end up
in our colon quite quickly
as soon as 15 to 20 minutes and so
cutting back on those bubbly waters and
switching to flat waters
can be really helpful and ridiculous
reducing that bloating and gas
my third tip is all about that gentle
movement
post baby because there can be a lot of
muscular and structural
changes i know you experience diastasis
recti
so making sure that uh you kind of move
to help that gas move along can be
helpful
gentle stretching yoga walking
your super fun diastasis recti
exercises and deep belly breathing
can help with abdominal wall tone
stretching that diaphragm getting that
pelvic floor functioning
a little bit better amazing okay
well i am ready and uh and
really got a lot to to think about here
but i think this is manageable and this
is
you know something that i'm much more
keen on doing and keeping up
versus taking on a massive elimination
diet especially considering
just like how much i have on my plate
right now so thank you so much andrea um
wish me luck yeah i hope you do great
with these tips
thank you okay folks
day one and just gonna finish off
my lacroix this is my favorite flavor
the peach pear
so good very refreshing
so so bubbly so sparkly so effervescent
so refreshing but also so gassy i get it
so
to make this transition a little easier
for myself i got this i don't know you
call this like an infuser like a water
infuser
so i'm going to put some blueberries
inside i feel like that'll add a little
bit more flavor make this a little bit
more exciting
i don't know i feel like i need to like
squish them you guys tell me
if my technique is totally off i don't
know i just feel like more flavor is
going to come out
if i squish them a little bit and a lot
of fruit is not
in season right now so i figure finish
off these blueberries
these are really good ones and then
maybe
move towards like frozen fruit for the
rest a week so we'll we'll switch it up
keep things interesting
so screw this bad boy on let's get some
water
i'm trying to be excited about this
okay look at this
i feel so feels so good
also you know i like having a nice
reusable water bottle so
and this is a really cool one too
[Music]
tastes pretty plain pretty boring maybe
i need some ice
ice yes like a cocktail or something
am i just lying to myself
why is it so hard to get off
it doesn't want me to have the ice
oh you know what elsa needs
lime yes yes lots of lime
just like let's make it taste like a gin
and tonic on a monday morning
okay let's try this again round two
getting excited
get pumped cannot wait for this flat
boring ass water all right
much better i mean it's not a cocktail
but it's something it's something we're
gonna make it through
all right
i'm gonna go through a lot of fruit this
week
[Applause]
this is gonna be the hard part because
i know what time it is and i have about
i don't know 20 seconds before e wakes
up so to eat this slowly
i think i'm gonna have to like give up
salads because it's gonna take me way
too long to eat this
i might have to switch to getting my
vegetables in via soup
via soup and smoothies for the next
little while until we can try this out
properly
can you hear oh screaming yeah that my
friends is why i have to wolf things
down really quickly
she has no idea of the toll a babe can
take on its mother
or its mother's mother okay so this
whole slow eating tip thing
is gonna be probably the hardest thing i
need to accomplish
this week as a mom and i'm sure all the
parents out there can
attest to this there's just like so few
hours and moments in the day for you to
have a peaceful meal never mind like a
peaceful sip of coffee
so me trying to juggle my work and
parenting two kids in covid times it's
like i'm lucky if i get to eat
period never mind get to eat in peace
and quiet
and like not rush through a meal when i
became a parent probably the first thing
that i noticed that changed was that i
started eating really quickly
and when i thought about it was like
because you just don't know when the
baby's going to wake up or someone's
going to have a meltdown or you're going
to have
something someone screaming at the table
you have to pass the pass the baby off
to your partner so that you can take
turns eating
because it's really hard to eat with a
baby on your lap especially like hot
things like
soup i think the key at this point is to
make sure my salads are like really
energy dense
like not lots of nuts and seeds and
quinoa and
you know other other little add-ins like
that because otherwise it'll take like
to fill me up i will be eating all day
long of just like vegetables and stuff
all right gonna try to get a quick walk
in with
oh here might not be the most relaxing
walk
but we're gonna get some exercise we're
gonna get that
all right we had a good little walk
there oh had a good
nap i hear i'm starting to kind of stir
so i'm gonna
get us inside but i definitely do feel
like my
digestion is feeling a little bit better
right now a little less gassy
i always find after like a little bit of
a light workout or some walking
that's generally when i feel my best so
i kind of think that it's when
i'm like laying in bed or really
sedentary when it really catches up with
me so
hopefully this gets us in a good spot
right before dinner and
he's ready for dinner okay so i actually
feel
a lot better this morning without the
sparkling water being like part of my
early morning routine like i probably
would drink a whole sodastream worth of
sparkling water when i wake up
um so instead i made another one of
these blueberry lime concoctions
probably will switch it up later on
today but for now i'm going to make
myself some tea
because i mean once i finish this then
i'm going to need more hydration and i
think it's time to have some like
flavor in there don't judge
it's good just got in from a
really brisk walk because it just got so
hot i'm not used to this it's middle of
november and that in canadian
is translated to mean winter so i was
like bundled up and i am
schvitzing i'm like coated in sweat
right now
so gonna go deal with that situation get
myself changed onto the next activity i
guess
i hear that oh is just getting ready to
wake up
time to do some of these really boring
ab exercises
there's no power crunches going on here
i'm not allowed to do that right now
they know you're like what are you doing
mommy no no
gross this is why i can't work out okay
okay
okay okay so some strategies i am
trying to employ with this whole like
chewing your
food slowly and making sure that it's
thoroughly chewed before you swallow it
not just like wolving it down
is a i'm choosing to eat basically only
when
the kid is asleep and i know that is
hard for a lot of people when we have
like times a day where we prefer to eat
maybe i'm not like super hungry yet
but i just know that if i wait until
maybe i am super hungry
that may also coincide with when the
baby wants to eat or the baby wants to
be changed
the baby wants to be entertained and the
baby's screaming so
i need to make some compromises here
typically when i eat things with like a
spoon
i would choose like the biggest spoon
that or the biggest fork that i have so
that i can
put more on the spoon and like get it in
my mouth faster with these two things
being employed together
i'm now using like a smaller spoon so
like less is getting on the spoon
and i cut up my strawberries small so
it's not like a huge chunk and i'm like
shoveling things in my husband's gonna
be very happy with this new protocol
because
he thinks i eat like a slob most the
time and it's true
i do and that is being out of complete
desperation to just feed myself or
something
happens so here's to a hopefully
peaceful meal while always asleep so
today's strategy for getting in my
veggie fix without having to
chew a salad for an hour is i just kind
of put them
into a vegetable soup and this is
actually a soup that i had made before i
gave birth and i just like froze like a
big
big bunch of it which is generally what
i do with soup lots of tomatoes some
zucchini lots of bell peppers black
beans
corn onions garlic i think probably
it's like a spicy kind of mexican style
soup it's really really tasty
but i'm just realizing now of course
after i thought it out that like the
beans
may undo the you know the benefits of
not having to chew all these raw
vegetables so we're gonna see how this
does
on my little gut we are going to see
it feels so wrong to
chew so much but i'm gonna try i think
one of the reasons it feels wrong
as a mom is because it almost feels like
i feel guilty that i'm taking this much
time
to feed myself i'm gonna enjoy this meal
so last night was not my best night i
had the worst abdominal cramps and
pain and bloating and gas and it was
like it kept me up at night and even
like into the morning i was not feeling
so great and that was like even though i
didn't have any sparkling water and
i chewed my food super super well in
fact i had
soup so that you know it was even easier
to digest
but that's actually probably why i was
having issues because we ordered in some
like japanese udon noodle soup which is
like my favorite thing
and it's like tons of noodles and it's
like a big bowl of salty broth
and like sauteed cabbage had like a
whole order of edamame to myself so it's
like my favorite meal
probably the combination of all the
cabbage and the beans
and the tons of salt probably didn't
feel so good to me and i totally get
that so it's like i'm always collecting
this data and i acknowledge it
but you know every once in a while i
still want to enjoy this meal so
i think this probably goes to show that
there may be some other underlying
ibs issues and symptoms and maybe some
food intolerances
the changes that i'm making right now
feel like changes that i can
realistically
stick to that actually feel good to my
body rather than
you know cutting out all the foods that
i love so maybe down the road i will
look into working with someone like
andrea to like really hone in on
any maybe smaller intolerances or any
kind of other triggers
right now i'm just sticking to these
small
manageable changes it's actually working
for me i feel like the progress that
i've made
is enough and i'm feeling really good
about it
so i'm totally going to drink this and i
don't feel like oh my gosh
i messed up on my diet i have a failure
i'm the worst
none of those thoughts are actually
going through my head right now because
i have to make
this you know sustainable it has to be
realistic something that i can do
forever that actually feels good to me
and having a sparkling water having my
beloved blacquah
feels good to me but i think what it
actually comes down to is that i'm
probably going to want to have
more of the sparkling water stuff in the
mornings when i'm more
active and that's when the gas is not so
bad and then
as i get towards the end of the day
towards dinner that's when i probably
want to switch to
flat because that's when i start to feel
a little bit more uncomfortable i'm not
doing as much activity i'm just like
sitting down at dinner and then laying
down in bed so i'm going to enjoy
my lacroix let's just enjoy this this
quick little sam
the sound effect for those of you who
are into that
[Music]
i just automatically do the pinky
because i'm fancy like that i'm super
bougie
i'm gonna enjoy this and back to
shooting
[Music]
[Music]
so here's a new little insight of mine
i think because i don't enjoy flat water
as much as sparkling
i'm actually drinking less water overall
that's kind of a problem for a
breastfeeding mom because i have noticed
my supply is
dipping a little bit so i think right
now i'm having to
kind of balance my competing priorities
and you know that is like bloating and
gas versus
feeding my baby you could totally say to
me like well you just need to try harder
out
you need to make a priority and you need
to just do better at remembering to
drink that water
sure you know you can judge me but i
also
have to you know acknowledge i'm like in
total survival mode right now
i am struggling right now to manage my
business
and parent two kids in a pandemic and
i'm okay with being
compassionate and kind to myself and
cutting myself some slack i'm just to do
what i feel like i can do and what i can
manage
what i'm going to try to do is fill up
that kind of fruity flavored water or
make some like iced tea
and focus on that you know first thing
in the morning when i'm more likely to
feel that thirst
and to feel like i have a real drive to
drink and then
to make that sparkling water available
to myself as an option for those times
when
maybe i'm less likely to or less
inclined to like
just like go and fill up my cup at least
that's what i'm gonna try
and we're gonna see how we can make this
into a sustainable habit
and i think this video is actually
becoming really all about
how to make a health promoting habit
that you can actually
stick to that is sustainable and i think
this is a really good lesson for
everyone for any kind of other health
promoting habits as well
i do have a long way to go i mean i'm
not like cured in a week or anything
which
of course would be unrealistic to even
think that was possible
and it will take me probably some time
to heal my diastasis recti erect die
which
i do think plays a big role in my issue
specifically
i know there's like a ton of videos and
blog posts out there promising to like
cure your bloating overnight
but for me a lot of those
recommendations that i read or see
or here are just not sustainable to me
at least
i mean i was not even interested in
never having sparkling water again but i
have found that just cutting back on it
a little bit
and of course kind of balancing that
with my competing priorities to like get
enough hydration has made a legitimate
difference
so i hope that this video stands out in
the sea of anti-bloating videos to help
you realize that you can get relief from
digestive
problems without extreme restriction and
sometimes it's a bit of a give and take
with your symptom management
and the other things going on in your
life and on that note that is all from
me today
please be sure to give this video the
thumbs up if you liked it
leave me a comment below on your
thoughts on this what has worked for you
um also if you like these kind of vlog
style videos and you want to see me do
more of them i'd love to do more of them
so let me know of course
subscribe to the channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye